I know I haven't got time to thank such
loyal friends is Edna Bernard and my
producer miss dessert Smith and
Universal all it's our Board of
Directors who've been have such
confidence in me like mr. mom
that was Jacqueline interrupting doctor
loans acceptance speech to remind her
that it was 1957 already
in 1983 our producer when he was
deciding of which of us hosts would be
which person second third or fourth
he decided alphabetically and he said no
then he said ages then he said no then
he said the tallest and sharpness
was it alright
as Howard caught you our producer who
talked me into doing the show exactly
was written ruining what little career
that might have had so he finally
decided on the really thing the only
thing that really mattered was beauty
and money now you have seen the money
part and here's the beauty water map
did I detect a satirical thrust no me no
man you're my favorite I mean you're a
role model for me ever since The Odd
Couple really no I saw it 16 times I
what are you doing getting the fluff off
oh you know when you were doing live on
Sunset Strip I took my whole family to
see it every single performance we
increased our vocabulary skills a
hundredfold
well educating the boudoir is my forte
you're a great educator Richard thank
you I'm fulfilled I'll see you at the
party thank you very much
this has been a great year audiences are
streaming into movie theaters and
unprecedented numbers once again people
are talking what they're saying is what
they've been saying since movies began
you get the popcorn
I'll get the orange track our next
presenters are the star of high road to
China and the actress who broke records
on Broadway as woman of the year Tom
Selleck and Raquel Welch
why I don't I don't be a see the
audience this is happy to see you here
tonight as I am well thank you but I've
got a sneaking suspicion that a lot of
that applause was for you we remove you
all enjoyed it it was terrific thank you
thank you very much
I think our editor has made a great
contribution though well they always do
editors are the unsung heroes of many a
film those men and women who stand spend
hours and cramped of the rooms running
film to their movie ollas and selecting
the proper shot to make a movie really
move the nominees for the best
achievement in film editing this year
our Hannes nickel for dust Boat Carol
Littleton for et
John bloom for Gandhi
Peter's dinner for an officer and a
gentleman
Frederick Steenkamp and William Stein
camp for Tootsie
and the winter rock though oh well
you've got so many muscles why don't you
tear it open for me okay the winner is
John bloom for gamba
Thank You members of the Academy thank
you to my colleagues Chris Ridsdale and
Allen Pattillo and thank you Richard for
making it possible we standing here
tonight clutching this lovely little
souvenir thank you very very much
thank you
I agree with Tom and Raquel about the
value of a good edit one of the things
I'd most like working for me is sort of
a life editor to cut out my mistakes
beautify some of my unbecoming
activities from a more scenic angle and
make sure that I really looked as
wonderful as I think I do while I have a
chance now I'd like to say that I've
been watching these Oscar ceremonies for
a number of years and again tonight I'm
absolutely thrilled at the display of
talent and the amazing production
numbers were seeing
the singers and dancers do our whole
industry prowl and now back to business